well we all saw it that slap in the face
overshadowing a celebration of the best
work in hollywood at last night's oscars
now the academy launching a formal
investigation will smith's first
appearance on stage slapping comedian
chris rock across the face after a joke
about smith's wife jada pinkett smith
mocking her shaved head christian well
kirsten smith suffers from alopecia
disease resulting in hair loss and last
night's incident is bringing it to the
forefront now it impacts both men and
women but one local dermatologist tells
us there are solutions
i don't condone it but i understand
this oscar night moment is sparking a
conversation about alopecia las vegas
dermatologist dr candice spann says it's
an emotional and devastating medical
condition especially for women 50
percent of women will experience some
form of alopecia by the time they're 50
years old
uniformly regardless of the type of
alopecia it's emotionally devastating dr
spann says most women don't notice the
problem until they've lost 50 percent of
their hair which she says can be caused
by several factors it can be vitamin
deficiency crash dieting styling
practices hormonal fluctuations
childbirth menopause stress covid
there's so many issues that affect
women's hair growth it's absolutely
possible to do something about it while
hair loss impacts both men and women
span says her office is getting a large
amount of patients suffering from
post-covet hair loss called telogen
effluvium we can help with that it's
just seeking out the help and getting
help instead of just stressing about it
at home because you're absolutely right
stress makes hair loss worse span says
our hair is an important element of who
we are that many times is overlooked but
now is front and center what will was
doing was defending jada and something
that was meant to be a harmless joke
that was clearly upsetting
well dr spann says it's important to get
a diagnose from a certified
dermatologist because there are many
types of alopecia simple things like
steroids and vitamins can be a great
solution